all right hello everyone my name is
Sally I'm a software engineer at Google
and I'm here at cube con with Greg
castle Greg is the tech lead of the
security team at gke
Greg you have a huge mandate can you
talk a little bit about what you work on
yeah so my team handles the security of
a bunch of parts of the gka system we
look out the security of monstas and
kind of security configurations of
musters as well as kind of helping out
with other teams that look after various
other subsystems so we interact with
storage we interact with the node team
networking a bunch of others and kind of
helped drive security direction across
the whole product as well as in the open
source we have a number of people on
sigilyph so we have a couple of kind of
the leaders in that community and we
have people on the kubernetes product
security team that kind of get all the
incoming security vulnerabilities for
communities and triage them and respond
to them so yeah a lot of stuff
internally and protecting gke
clusters and also externally protecting
kubernetes clusters in general that is a
lot of stuff that you work on let's
focus in a little bit on the open source
side of things where are things as they
stand today and where are they going in
the future yeah so I think we've made a
lot of progress recently we've some
interesting kind of areas that have seen
a fair bit of focus in 2018 have been
service accounts so Mike Denis and I are
talking about this on Thursday you can
come to the container identity what can
group deep dive where we're going to
talk a bit about how we kind of had
these older service accounts that
kubernetes first started with that had a
number of security problems that were
have been addressing in 2018 and moving
to a kind of a new model and the
difference is mainly that those that
first generation of service accounts
were basically static keys that lived in
the secrets database they live forever
it was very difficult to rotate them so
we've had some security kind of
incidents where a key you know with
various like subsystems of kubernetes
where
he was kind of leaked in some way and
then we need to move on to a new
kubernetes service account and revoke
those old credentials and it's all very
painful in the kind of current version
of service accounts and so we've
developed a bunch of api's and kind of
some new ways to mount in these new
kubernetes service account secrets that
no longer involve that centralized
database you can they can be like kind
of scoped and sort of bound to a pod so
a lot of things get get easier so
they're limited lifetim the cubelet will
handle rotation of them automatically
for you the kind of client go
communities libraries have being updated
so that the the users the consumers of
those service account tokens don't have
to worry too much about it as long as I
using a client library so and they can
be audience bound which is it which is a
new thing too so previously there wasn't
any audience funding which meant those
tokens weren't particularly useful
outside of or that once safely useful
outside of the cluster and now we can
say all right you can go to the
kubernetes master and say give me a
credential that I want to go use with
Hoshi Colt Volt or I want to go
authenticate to some other system and
you can say this token should only be
used with that destination system and
that destination system wouldn't then be
able to turn around and take it back to
the API server and and have some control
over the API server that that service
account has so there's quite a bit of
there's been a lot of work in that in
2018 and Mike in particular Mike Denis
has led a lot of that in the community
and so we're just now getting to a point
so some of those API eyes are in beta
one of them's in alpha and one thirteen
but we're getting to a point where we
need kind of people to start using them
and and get feedback on them so if
that's interesting I definitely look at
the container identity working group
deep dive session I would talk about
that in some more detail that sounds
like a lot of awesome work going on on
the open source side of things so I
think folks are gonna be looking forward
to seeing service account rotations
becoming something that they can start
using can you talk a little bit more
about what's going on the gke side of
things in terms of keeping customers
secure
yeah so the that service account work is
is playing into a larger identity effort
at Google so we we know there's some
some kind of usability pain and some
security things that we'd like to
address with accessing Google services
so getting access to Google credentials
to access Google services is currently
more painful than it should be and so
this this work we're doing in the
community is kind of foundational for
for that work to improve that identity
integration with Google and so there's
there's active active work in that area
we're not quite ready to announce it yet
but if you are a gk customer definitely
talk to us about it and we can get you
involved early in that in that process
and so we'll be improving the security
of the identity integration with Google
and and the usability of it as well too
and I think that's gonna be quite
powerful and flexible so that's been a
big focus for our team
there's kind of some other efforts on
the way under like a general I'd say
hardening bucket so we're both in
kubernetes and on the Google side so on
the kubernetes side we've added the
ability for the cubelet to be bootstraps
from a what's called a trusted platform
module which is a kind of like trusted
cryptographic device that can be used a
kind of as a route of trust for for
things and so we want to be able to have
a kind of like strong cryptographic way
to bootstrap nodes that's better than
like some sort of shared key that we
give to nodes to say this is a thing
that should be able to join the cluster
ideally we'd have something like a TPM
that can say here's a cryptographic
assertion that says Who I am and then
write rules about who should be able to
join the cluster and so we've added that
functionality into kubernetes and we're
working on kind of interesting Google
side stuff for that too so yeah no one
else would say yet either but yeah
there's there's more interesting stuff
coming cool so it sounds like a lot of
new cool functionality to make
kubernetes more secure on gke
can you talk more about the bug bounty
program and what we do to discover
vulnerabilities and how we deal with
them yeah so in a few different fronts
Google has its own
bug bounty program right now so you can
if you find a security vulnerability in
gke
or in really any Google product in
within the scope of the bug bounty and
GK is in in scope for the bug bounty
then we will pay you money so please try
out test test the bounds of the GK
security and we're happy to receive
those and we're happy to pay for those
those vulnerabilities
similarly the CNC F is also standing up
its own bug bounty program and that's
currently in process now so we're
working on kind of setting up the
structure for that to be able to handle
those those vulnerabilities coming in
from a program like that and that will
also set kubernetes up in a good place
to also looking at some kind of for
kubernetes in the scene cf is also kind
of looking at some threat modeling and
and that kind of work too so yeah it's
the bug bounty program I think is kind
of a symbol of an organization being
mature enough to know that security bugs
do happen and if we can force x like
taking advantage of that great security
researcher community and paying for them
for their effort it is a lot of effort
to find security vulnerabilities and a
lot of cases then yeah I think it's a
real symbol of maturity and something
that we'd love to see replicated as
widely as possible cool and I understand
we work very closely with partners to
make sure that our entire ecosystem is
safe can you introduce shop fly yeah
yeah so Shane do you want to come over
how do you join us on camera here so
Shane and I are presenting on Thursday
we're actually in the very last coming a
little bit we're in the very last time
slot on Thursday so please stick around
for us but we're talking about a kind of
in that same vein of bug bounty programs
we're talking about a security issue
that was reported to the Shopify bug
bounty program that I think is a really
interesting example that for the
community in general that we can learn
from when when companies share these
kind of experiences I think it's very
valuable to be
the details of them be fairly open about
them and talk about kind of how the
attack work how the vulnerability was
just discovered how it played out what
the possible defenses are and kind of
learn from it as a community so yeah hey
maybe you can tell us a little bit about
the Shopify bug bounty program and how
that got started sure Greg
so I'm Shane from Shopify and the
mission of the security team at Shopify
is to make commerce more secure for
everyone and to that end we have a
comprehensive security posture but we
know that there are always going to be
bugs so our bug bounty program allows
hundreds of researchers to participate
attempt to hack our platform and if
they're able to find vulnerabilities
then there's a financial incentive for
them to disclose those responsibly once
they make that responsible disclosure we
will patch it as soon as we find out
about it and correct the problem and as
soon as we know that we're secure again
we release that out to the public and
that way other companies can take
advantage of this information and
through collaboration we can all make
the platform's more secure so did you
want to jump back in or how do you yeah
so do you have any recommendations for
other customers who are working with
kubernetes or gke and what they can do
to improve their security on their
systems absolutely so one of the ways
that we've been able to do this is by
working really closely with our partners
so whenever we find a vulnerability or
we suspect there may be an opportunity
for a vulnerability then we discuss it
with our partners at Google and we get a
good handle on what the risk of attack
is and what would happen if it were
compromised and if it seems like there's
a high severity there we might be able
to mitigate it on our own platform but
that doesn't help anyone else so we can
release that information or we can
incorporate it into tools we have for
instance an open-source tool called cube
audit that anyone can use and patches
are very welcome and in that way we're
able to improve the security posture
other people can share their knowledge
with us we can share Arnall
with them and in addition to that we
found that one of the biggest things
that prevents people from taking part in
bug bounty programs is low bounties so
if you're not financially compensated
for your work then researchers will move
on to someone else so shop flies very
proud that we offer above-average bug
bounties we offer substantial financial
compensation and in that way when
researchers find problems with our
platform they're encouraged to report it
and they're encouraged to keep coming
back and it really shows that we value
their time and the effort that they put
into it I think that goes a long way to
helping you secure the entire ecosystem
so thank you for that if we could switch
gears a little bit let's talk about cute
con this is not your first coupon no
actually this is the second time that
I've been at cube con I was able to
attend last year in Austin it was my
first time I'd been using kubernetes for
about a month at the time so I was
pretty new but I'm really excited to be
back here today are there any security
related talks that you're excited about
of course yours coming up tomorrow maybe
you want to tell folks about that sure
so there was a specific incident that
happened about six months ago where one
of our security researchers found a
vulnerability in our platform and it
combined a couple of things that may
have seemed like they were low risk on
their own but combined they could have
led to complete control of a cluster and
so we paid our maximum bounty of twenty
five thousand dollars for that and we're
really proud of the work that we did we
received the report and within an hour
and four minutes we were able to
mitigate that vulnerability and I think
that some of the work that we've done
there will be really valuable to others
who are trying to secure their own
platforms so I'm going to be sharing
that alongside my co-presenter Greg and
I'm really excited I think that some of
the details will be valuable I also
really enjoyed seeing my aquezio skis
talk yesterday on security and I think
that was a an incredible talk I thought
one of the most important things that
she covered there was the fact that
there are all of these container escapes
that everyone's really excited about the
really glamorous are sophisticated and
almost no one's using those in the wild
so I was really happy to hear her talk
about
that sounds awesome so if folks are
interested please check out these talks
and thank you so much for your time have
a great rest of your Q con
[Music]